[Music]
1983 is a new Netflix original show that
is currently flying under the radar but
definitely deserves your attention the
show is set in a dystopian reality that
features heavy parallels with the book
1984 by George Orwell obviously there's
a lot to unpack from the show and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about season one and its ending there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you're
yet to see it then I highly suggest that
you turn off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to set twenty years after a series
of devastating bomb blasts rocked Poland
in 1983 we follow a group of resistance
fighters that start to rise up against
their totalitarian and government since
the terrorist attacks of the government
have increased security to the detriment
of freedom and there are very clear
parallels to be drawn between our
current climate of the privatization of
personal information episode 8 titled
Requiem concludes the series by bringing
together a lot of dangling plot points
and answering many questions that the
show posed one of the big reveals in the
show is that we finally discovered that
there was a spy working within the light
brigade all along the light brigades
plan was to infiltrate the Trask a
network and relay a message about the
truth of the mass disappearances however
before they could broadcast the message
the s be stormed their headquarters and
killed the majority of their members we
learn that Powell had tipped the SP off
and see him in the morgue surrounded by
his dead comrades which clearly shows
that he was in on the ambush the whole
time Fe who was seemingly killed during
the encounter can be seen twitching her
fingers in the final episode which to me
highlights that she is still alive and
will be around for season two because
the operation was a success for the SB
Anatole was commended and promoted to
the Homicide Division I believe this was
done on purpose to pull him away from
the case as he in cotton stumbled across
the conspiracy and obviously the further
away that he is from it the less it can
play on his mind at the end of season 1
cassia tan hope I'm not messing his name
up ends up in America after being told
to board the plane by his duplicitous
girlfriend he met with Carolina's
Minister Father
wladislaw I really hope I'm not messing
this up who informed him that he wasn't
sure if he would be meeting the
President or not
flash forward and we see cassia tan in
an American Library where he's met by a
spy this led the character to be
reunited with his mother it was thought
dead after being killed by spies
one of the most ambiguous questions is
that of Ladislas true motives
it appears he may be in fact working
with the American government to take
down Poland from the inside but this
remains to be seen the fact that cassia
tire managed to meet with his mother
shows that perhaps he is one of the good
guys but in the show with this many
twists and turns you can never be sure
so what are your thoughts on 1983 did
you enjoy season 1 and where do you
expect it to go in the future
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of this
week's other big TV reveal the flash
which will be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to Definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]